time handicaped 30 minutes crazytown
experience level 30 here we go
alrighty double those points Oh that'd
be me to it
give me this gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme French the French advance I'm
gonna sack that pun am i doing I'm gonna
take that just take it you're gonna push
here push my bishop around I'm gonna
stay on this diagonal now let's get this
in I have that covered they're gonna
take on that square it's a blunder
they're not gonna do that
I can't move my pieces ah I can't move
my pieces I'm gonna take that
oh my computer is crawling can you see
that by how I'm moving it's like very
jagged jagged jagged jagged jagged how
did you pawn push or something
oh that's annoying pin Oh bad stuff is
happening my bishop takes there would
have been very good I don't have any
time this is terrible and I cannot move
quick if I need to move quick I can't
move quick oh no no no no no no give me
four excuse me Forks give me Forks come
on I can't even move my pieces that's
mate though pack to tournament this is
not good my best friend Mouse is not ah
well I don't know it's not even my mouse
it's my computer it's crawling and it's
having a terrible impact on my mouse get
going here
let's go I can't go so smoothly ah ah
come on now
come on get your act together there we
go it's a little bit smoother maybe
Castle kingside you want to do that you
know you want to do that maybe that dark
square bishop hit pawns out on dark
squares no pawn push again and then I
get the Queen if f4 still if f4 pawn
push is working out break down the dark
squares break them down break it down
pin night uh-oh uh-oh
bishop here pawn push so I could take
here twice without fear of f7 the knight
has to be defended it's not defended
it's a free night let's come back here
take here next now I can take here mmm
I really don't want to even take that
who cares about that punk
who cares about them let's go [ __ ] up
let's go [ __ ] up sixteen where is the
time impact attack with Terry's nine
okay this is good this is good so far ah
I have a good feeling about this
tournament I really don't I really don't
have a good feeling about it oh my
goodness oh that's a wonderful move okay
now space advantage
space space watch out for a killer check
for the worst
get out of there not here not here
there's serious trouble serious trouble
bishop block if there's a check bad
things are happening checker ruski for
kirovsky there's no good solution clean
here deadly fork this might be resigned
Time Queen here oh the Queen has to give
herself up that's tough that's a tough
one to stomach isn't it
that's a toughy I think in resign
they're not gonna resign develop get
your pieces out bishop
castle they resigned back to tournament
12 let's do this all righty
Oh problems with the Philippines
problems in the Philippines land ah it's
not pairing me up hit me with the air
gimme points air and then points in the
meantime let me do some homework what
are you talking about Totoro Vic no
forget about Totoro Vic I see Wolfman
where's wolf man wolf man's here haha
that's about wolf man I know about him
still have nightmares who knows about
0.1 seconds I do firsthand 0.1 seconds
nightmares still to this day nothing
here where are you at Wolfman still
nothing here this is wonderful stuff
where are you I can't find them I want
to do some home prep still nothing here
come on
yes give me air and gimme points leaders
leaders leaders how many I get I got
four-way leg is up there oh and this guy
is well all this guy's so fast if I
don't move fast I'm totally dead I can
tell you right now this guy goes
incredibly quick give me that night I'll
take him
I will take him okay I gotta get this
guy this guy always beats me up always
give me that light square bishop let me
get in here sneak attack my knight wants
to be here they must be scared is my
opponent scared I didn't really want to
do that my queen needs to get on see oh
I'm okay okay you take this and then do
that it's a wonderful commentary take
this and then do that I'm going to take
this and then do that
are you is that we're going to do our
outcast in this direction to take this
and then do that is the plan I just want
to open this up oh this is gonna be made
hahahaha that's me yes gimme gimme gimme
back to tournament 24 I needed that that
was a big win that guy usually gives me
a beating and a half this one again
Oh what is this the air gambit the the
seller the seller gambit man there's no
you can't do anything about this this
does work out from time to time though
this did happen at one point it is
exactly what I needed right in the last
second if I had to play an actual game
and get points I would have been enough
time but there was one where it wouldn't
start up and I had just enough gas
enough of a boost
where's Wolfman where's Wolfman here he
is it Scott I have trouble even looking
at this image right here nightmares
nightmares that this reminds me of that
that character in the neverending story
the nothing haha who knows what I'm
talking about
he's have to be a little older for that
movie the neverending story who knows
about it look at this if you could see
it a little guy right there mean he's
mean he's bad news and air isn't in
effect give me the points give me the
points I probably got points I wasn't
able to go to it though I probably got
the points I wasn't able to go to it all
right
alrighty damn file opened up no you
don't want to drop pieces take care I
should have taken their okay I could
take here twice if push okay this is for
free now play for free what do I mean by
that I mean that I have this F file and
for my opponent has no compensation for
that
uh-oh pieces are dying dead pieces
Castle castle and then just take that
night out
development develop your pieces
get out of there Bishop you need to go
somewhere else somewhere else is where
you need to go my night is boxing out
that bishop back up here pawn push rook
right here maybe maybe c4 c4 what's so
funny what's so funny they're saying now
I have a pin what's so funny
pins take the rook resign time I'd be
resigned time it's not resigned time
pigs pigs in a past a pawn pigs in the
past a pond is what everybody tries to
get pigs in the past a pond no
stalemates they also like to avoid
stalemates that's me back determine come
on gimme gimme gimme gimme
leaders leaders 39:38 oh man what a
tight pack up there okay here we go see
five 20 minutes and change remaining in
this tournament I need a quick win no no
no no no no no let's stop nonsense on b5
no nonsense allowed keep my queen right
there I'm looking for made on this it's
not there right happened it because of
this structure this is check now an
isolated pod coming up I'm okay with
this F file opening up rook here and
target that B to pond if the pond pushes
I get the night it might happen pom push
I get this guy I just get this guy and
I'm on the night I have that covered or
no I don't they're going to take my
night and then look for me they're being
sneaky sneaky 'no severy where you got
to watch out for that pond here no just
take this night and then run away here
man 25 seconds I got to move this pond I
want to my bishop to hit the Queen
there's pomp which might happen very
soon it's not happening
now let's go here my queen wants to
maybe come over here go I'm not going
fast enough
ah ee v e4 a bishop wants to play this
pawns in a pin what are they doing
I'm Dart I'm guarding my knight Oh
what's going on here a sac I'm on the
bishop oh this is crumbling pawn takes
pawn it's me my favorite way c1 anyone
back to tournament 51 50 52 51 50 oh man
what a tight pack up there
18 change oh okay stay focused now stay
focused stay focused all right oh what's
going on could I have just snipped here
I probably could have then do it
oh what's the delay what's the delay you
could probably do it then do it oh oh
checks watch out for the tricky checks
watch out for the tricky mates oh oh
rook here now it's check one two three
four five three four
now I miscounted but eventually that's
me there it is back to tournament 65 65
52 that was not all calculated no it's
the Wolfman oh oh I already feel like
I've had a disadvantage no The Wolfman
haha oh no no no no no I think I can I
think I can I think I can am i quoting
The Wizard of Oz now haha
lions and tigers and Wolfman the lions
and tigers and don't forget about the
Wolfman come on you could do it you
could do it you could do it you could
beat the Wolfman you could beat the wolf
you could do it I think I can I think I
can
and get that night get no why'd I do
that no this is the beginning of the end
no oh no no no no no oh and wise have to
be so difficult Oh every time the wolf
man no no take my Brooke oh no no I'm
telling the exchange why is this
happening wolf man oh I gotta go here I
have to be so difficult oh man come on
you could do it you could do it you
could do it you could do it come on no
no no no no no no no defend defend
defend I need to focus on time I don't
have any time my bishop is in trouble oh
my name is run away I only have time I
could only ever beat the Wolfman on time
that's it that's all I ever have is time
maybe maybe Oh No I am so dead I got a
block with my knight this is terrible
that's wrong - check it's a good time
burner right here 12 seconds I know the
Wolfman could beat me very easily
oh no no no time time time I gotta watch
out for the point one seconds 0.1
seconds oh no no no no I gotta run I
gotta run I gotta run don't make me
don't make me don't make me don't make
me don't make me please don't make me
don't make me why am I going in this
direction I got it don't we ever time oh
man oh that guy scares me so much oh man
ah man just follow the yellow brick road
man it's gonna be okay it's gonna be
okay is this guy moving that didn't even
make sense when I just said bet
Oh 95 90 alright alright calm yourself
here found yourself regroup quit holding
your breath deep breaths deep breaths oh
man why'd I play Bishop f6 did I really
like doing that to my pawn structure
that was beautiful wasn't it
Oh a sneak attack right there ah they
missed that they're playing on though
they're playing on it feels good not to
be down the exchange I tell ya it feels
wonderful not to be down the exchange oh
is this gonna kill me
well let's just open up the F file more
exchanges more exchanges are okay it's
okay I have it's okay everything's gonna
be okay um let's go here let's go here
that's probably not a good move
all right let's trade I want to get this
right here
there's pawn I get that poem or night
here let's protect that Oh why'd I do
that why did I do that
okay pawn push okay pawn push my knight
has a home f4 is it f4 incoming landing
captured towards the center no well I
guess either ones okay I got this pawn
now it's crumbling crumbling time take
another guy I should take an that one
he's more important so I could get this
pawn going I guess it doesn't matter
still win right
King position over here let's give a
check get this pawn rolling pons pons
pons time is okay no issues with time
uh-huh where is there
I got this run I got it unless I gave it
the Comcast gambit now they're down on
time back to term at 1:10 I have a lead
no I don't
one-fifteen one-ten anton squared anton
squared all righty
d5 is that going to come in with tempo
no it's not if it is it's going to be
baby step okay I have out the f7 square
f7 I should taking that pond now let's
come over here there would have been a
queen d4 check Bishop takes here's a
threat or is it I got to run here
I have Bishop here I have to block let's
just get out of that it's scary let's
back up that night I don't want to give
that up right here I got to go here I
have to defend my knight Knight f5 oh he
needs to go light squares bishop pair
Bishop takes pawn as a threat serious
threat g6 does not save the day I could
take I'm on this I can take it Sam ain't
enough on push matin 1/2 that pawn is
pinned resign don't be a clock ticker no
clock tick back determine 1:30 I have a
lead this time either lead for probably
just for a split second Panthers
what's with all these animals the
animals are attacking everywhere the
Panther the wolf um ok all right let's
go here maybe oh stop that stop that
give me that dark square Bishop and then
they don't want to give up that dark
square Bishop huh what is that you can
do let's go here
we're gonna have a night trade is this
okay I think it should be mm all right
I'm at night more trades I want to get
my majority going eventually now I'm on
the Queen and then the bishop I get a
piece from this 31 seconds and now the
knight is ready to kill me let's stop
that
I want to guard this d5 square let's
come over here and let's castle in this
direction take with my bishop on the
knight twice okay okay just stop that so
my knight can now move get this pawn
rolling a little bit and then get my
knight to one of these two squares this
one maybe maybe everything's are maybe
isn't it everything is a maybe all right
I have the control over the to pawn
breaks why'd I even do that all right
let's go Knight the rooks gonna take
okay I could now let's just defend here
Queen here why don't why am i allowing
this counter play why is that clean
getting so active because I'm not
playing aggressive enough
grab this ten seconds trick Queen trade
please give me Queen trade would you
just open this up right here F's I'm
just gonna do even if it's wrong it's
not wrong
where's the mate it's pin nasty pin
that's me Oh back to tournament 1:55 150
way leg is up there twelve twelve twelve
or we both have 12 games in is what I
meant okay Wow 155 150 years ago f4
Knight f3 less than ten minutes
remaining in this tournament pawn push
to stop d5 with tempo now I'm just going
to back up I'm not going to take here
this is something I said earlier in the
stream maintain that pawn on E
now let's come over in this direction
Queen h4 Grand Prix like alright I guess
this guy is dead I'm gonna take this
night I might want to take this guy
okay I can still get the darks for
bishops off and then the night and I'm
going to go with this I want to keep
that night out of these two squares pawn
push Bishop there okay that's not
happening change of plans I don't see
any attack against the king at this
point so let's come over here and then
get my Bishop on e3 oh that [ __ ] is
gonna be very good I want to get my
Bishop my knight my knight right here
he'd be very annoying and now I could
get rid of that light square Bishop he's
a number one priority now it's free as a
free as a free piece now I'm up what
what am i up I am up full rook full Rock
I'm up oh I'm glad I have that available
um let's take here and now this is
winning a piece well I'm just gonna take
care it's simpler take that pig not a
pig
um oh that's main as a helpmate back to
term of 170 175 178 minutes and change
ah man
here he is this is the leader uh uh this
is a big one this is a big one he knows
all about the fishing poles all about
him all about him why'd I do that move
this is the this is the leader right
here this is a big game come on you
could do it you could do it you could do
it uh-huh over here this pond rolling
get out of here night I could get this
in there's no pawn push now I have this
I have this pond not the game I
definitely don't have the game
definitely don't have the game over here
get rid of that LightSquared bishop Oh
get out of the pin so i can recapture
otherwise my queen would have been
unprotected how can I get my knight here
can I get that no I can't no stop it
right now let's go over here
get that Bishop out of there take here
in that pond push man lay here right
here right here let me take here first
um what's the clock situation I have
time to look at the clock get that night
out of there it's okay I just want to
get rid of him
pawn push open up the F file 25 seconds
let's take this and then nasty stuff is
happening really soon Knight takes f4
uh-oh trouble I think the pawn has to
push all the way it's made on G to check
tricky Knights tricky Knights tricky
Knights get rid of that Bishop looking
for me I'm on f3 twice oh I could just
take that pawn there's got to be mate
really soon
why'd I do that ah I can't move fast I
should've given up the Queen I should
not have given up the Queen where's the
checks tricky checks right here where
are the tricky checks I got the rook I
got the rook what do I have
let's just take this I have at least a
draw run pond run run run run run you're
fast you're fast you're fast run over
here six no stalemates now why am i
doing it like this they're going to
resign they resigned that's a
big win a 190 175 Anton Anton again
aka Anton squared here we go for the
Matthies for the Mathies how creative
that was right
how creative Oh more bad jokes oh no I
made it haha no
Anton Squared me oh man I just fell for
us a scholars made I just got scholar
no no no you didn't see that don't tell
your friends don't I even do it
oh no no no only one thing could maybe
make up for it but no not even if 17
fishing poles can make up for that
that was awesome to watch not to play
let me tell you that was not fun no it
wasn't oh man I just got scholar
wha oh man that's what I get that's what
a pre move will do to you every time was
that even a pre move and I'm making
stuff up give me that Bishop oh I better
somehow win this still Oh No
if I thought the Wolfman scared me I am
going to be having nightmares of the
scholars mate the scholars made a
back-to-basics
just 101 where you at where are you at
chess 101 I can't even focus yeah no I
can't focus these conditions I can't
stop laughing oh man Oh was it really
that funny it was really that painful
actually ha ha ha
redemption
oh man oh man I don't even know what to
think anymore three minutes and change
Oh like this I think I have to mute the
stream oh oh man I don't even know what
to think
I'm really dizzy right now now hold my
breath but uh laughing okay
come on regroup you could do it Oh
f5 give me a five get out of checks
watch f2 that's could be my mantra
anymore
watch f2 it'll kill you in a blink okay
here we go stay focused now your pawns
are gonna be Swiss cheese very soon no I
have f6 maybe Oh baby
maybe oh man okay is this gonna be
decent I should have just pushed Oh
get out of there bishop my LightSquared
bishop needs to relocate let's take that
LightSquared bishop you want to get to
where over here okay I gathered myself a
little bit if you didn't realize oh
right here right here
stay focused two minutes and change I
got to get this one and maybe one more
really quick I have to reserve time to
get one more in one more one more one
more
there's nothing even over here why am i
trying to get on
that's a stupid diagonal why would I
even want to go there look up and over
maybe time burners I just I just dropped
my queen okay there's there's not going
to be any time though no time you can't
make me no time no time no time back to
chairman less than two to 28 to 25 oh no
no
what is it what is it what is it okay
here we go one minute 36 I have about
ten seconds I have to win this in about
ten seconds to be assured unless they're
a resigner watch out for my f7 the
corresponding F to square the
corresponding F to square you gotta
watch out for that one
oh man take like that they're gonna rip
this open my dark square bishop needs to
come back to defend where is my time ah
okay let's do this a pawn push is going
to be a killer isn't it I got to take on
that square twice the bishops going to
move I could come back though think
right here one minute remaining one
minute remaining I got to do Primos
pre moves pretty moves Primo's I got to
try this I think that's not a good one
I'm on the knight twice are they gonna
resign they're gonna be down a piece
down a piece 44 seconds 44 seconds
remaining I got a pre move everything I
can't let my clock tick don't let my
clock tick anything right here I can't
let my clock tick just let my opponents
clock tick oh they took my knight why'd
they do that what's with these pre moves
go go go go go go 22 seconds remaining
20 seconds remaining 18 seconds can I
get that oh no no no no no that was too
valuable pigs I need pigs pigs pigs come
on come on come on ten seconds remaining
can I get this can I get that mate
where's the main where's the mate making
one mate one mate one come on there's
only two seconds there's only two
seconds anything anything anything
anything anything anything what did I
get what I get when I get third oh I was
so close ah man
ah man that would have propelled me to I
would had 48 oh man
ah that was so close I had a chance I
chance oh man good games all f2 oh man I
got F tude